[Music]
you
Oh neighborhood champ five years in a
row hey can I give it a try me yeah no
no is not an answer come on so easy it's
a bad idea I'll even show you the famous
Craver sting grip okay you're put on
your hands now hold it like a pencil no
[ __ ] your wrist
good good elbow out and then use kind of
throw at it this is good
uh well kind of throw like a girl yeah
but when a girl is as beautiful as you
she doesn't have a good do you mind if I
skip the Kristen grift hey good luck
maybe I should show you how to throw
like a girl
Daphne you ready for level 4 security
clearance okay okay here we go
Karl yeah yeah like a a red dot on your
forehead
it's called adult acne thank you very
how are you hard
Charlotte no honey it's just a lotta it
burns it works vent out let's run for
Cole's house when I get killed out here
getting the car why did you tell us it
that I said get in the car
we're gonna get in the car guys now and
I count to three Oh gonna run okay one
two Jeff oh my god that's right Jeff
needs would you just get in the car how
was we gonna hit starts on your wife
Natalie
ever since we tried on underwear
together I realized something I've been
living a lie
welcome to the Cobra Club well now this
is Jeff's first time so I don't worry
we'll take good care of him man bye dad
thank you oh I'll take gosh she's you
what yep yeah - dude yeah
whatever he's happy to say Jews coming
up I gotta tell you spice and I don't
sit very well together
there's certainly ramifications the next
day you know Twitter wise Billy this is
not that yeah yeah yeah here we go okay
all right look at all these little
ethnic condiments so clean that is soy
sauce soy sauce try this okay mmm what's
that that looks like a snake
hit you man snake wine that's real Cobra
do you have tab I told you something was
off about the Joneses they're not who
they say they are gotta go
Oh Karen now hey what a surprise huh um
uh you've got no clothes on you're on
the phone I'm gonna go to be continued
who's this living team a voicemail Oh
likes to hear from me when I'm trying on
lingerie yeah it's one of our things
keeps the spark alive dad Jeff anything
yes Jeff and I have a thing we uh we do
it really fast in case the kids come
running into our room hmm
this is what I love about HR you learn
these little intricacies about people
Margaret's gonna show us a meaning of
trust honey what am I really doing this
summer then I sent the kids away to camp
I'm redesigning bathrooms sink Brooklyn
exposed brick and a urinal meg wants me
standing up again new neighbors aren't
wasting any time moving in are they hey
honey you'll spy it on the neighbors
hi we're the Joneses such a lovely
Street the Chinese don't even have a
word for a street like this they could
say I shouldn't be hood Englander quite
as a default
it sounds cool coming out of your mouth
you don't think there's something off
about them they're all so overly
accomplished into silent welcome to the
Cobra Club little differently expected
huh that's like a real snake snake why
that's real Cobra
do you have tab I'm following
Natalie Jones Oh Karen Natalie I was
just leaving tema voicemail likes to
hear from me when I'm trying on lingerie
it's one of our things Dan Jeff have a
think we do it really fast in case the
kids come running into our room hmm are
these people we need evidence I just
want to make sure this is not Erin Toya
what there's a missile honey is that you
mama wants to cuddle the job here's the
thing about trust once it's gone bad
things happen because John just get the
car now
I count to three arrangement okay one
two oh my god you can't be serious on
your why hello sweetie you know the
cookies Ty's been fitted with a
miniature surveillance mic it's
completely undetectable we don't get out
very often so we really like to make the
most of it
hello I'm dr. Drew and I'm dr. Willits
best time people often ask us dr. drew
dr. Ruth what is the perfect date movie
to answer this question we developed a
new scientific measurement we call it
the stimul action scale it measures the
film's effect on the male tumescence and
the female sex drive it sounds cool
coming out of your mouth I would have
publicist requires seven unique elements
the only film with all seven is keeping
up with the Jones this Finn is short
dresses
DJ Knight is Vincent before an accent
quite as a default
it's a snake restaurant and express
little sir panda Jon Hamm hi lingerie
and girl-on-girl kissing huh what is
happening to my life keeping up with the
Joneses is a very powerful aphrodisiac
only watch it for someone you really
love thank you OS yeah this extra the
love of her life
nope lemmings are in the house yes oh my
god
well looks like he works out quite a bit
step you get him up here
please feet please